Speaker 1: We have been on this story
from the beginning, and it has now been
confirmed exclusively by Newsweek based on a
classified report that they have obtained, that,
yes, Russian President Vladimir Putin
has received treatment for cancer and
has suffered an assassination attempt, which
we will talk about as well. Now, if you've been
watching our show, listening to the podcast,
this general story would not be new to you.
There are many media outlets that have not even
talked about this possibility. But our audience,
many of you will remember this. It seemed
that something was wrong back on April 25th,
when we reported in a segment called Visibly
Bloated Putin Grips Table for support in new video
that something seemed very wrong. And that was
after earlier speculation from some doctors in
our audience that something seemed just not
quite right with Vladimir Putin. Now, then,
in May, we reported on the belief that Putin had
cancer. It was more specifically being discussed
at that point in time. And three days after we
did that video, Ukraine's head of intelligence,
Major General Carillo Bogdanov, told UK's Sky News
that Putin was in, quote, a very bad psychological
and physical condition and he is very sick.
But okay. I mean, that's Ukraine's head of
intelligence. It may be accurate, but Ukraine
may also have reasons to push that narrative.
And the context here is very important,
because the question we've been asking is,
why is Putin acting so seemingly belligerently?
This invasion of Ukraine seems like a bad idea.
It's now been going on even longer, and it's not
clear that it's one that necessarily Russia's
going to be able to, quote, win, at least not
decisively, at least not without suffering
massive losses on which we've already reported. So
one of the theory actually I shouldn't say theory,
even though I mean theory colloquially
one of the hypotheses or speculations was
if Putin were ill, either as a result of he feels
like he has nothing to lose or as a side effect
of medication, all speculative. Maybe he's not
thinking clearly and he's acting belligerently and
he wants to go out in some kind of blazing glory
trying to return Russia to the USSR era. You know,
again, it was all speculative, but the question
was, could something medical maybe relate to
why he's behaving in this way? And the answer now
appears to be, well, at least maybe because it now
has apparently been confirmed that Putin
was treated for cancer. And we're going to
talk about what specifically is being reported.
A classified U.S. report obtained by Newsweek
says that Vladimir Putin has reemerged after
undergoing treatment for cancer in April for what
they are describing as quite advanced cancer,
according to three U.S. intelligence leaders
from this classified report. The report also
confirms that there was an assassination attempt
on Putin's life in March. Now, we've seen
these videos of when Putin meets with people,
he's he sits very far from them, these
cartoonishly long tables. And that applies to
other people that work for him within Russia,
but also even sometimes when he meets with
foreign leaders. And there were two speculations
there. One speculation is he's worried about an
assassination attempt, including maybe that the
people even that work for him might turn on him
and try to kill him. Now it is learned that he
did. There was an assassination attempt in March.
Secondly, the speculation was, well, maybe
he's just like really afraid of COVID.
Maybe because he's immunocompromised as a result
of possible treatment that he's receiving many
cancer treatments and other treatments can
suppress your immune system. And that would be
another potential explanation. This report doesn't
clarify whether it's one or the other or both,
because both things appear to have to appear to be
true. Three intelligence officials from the office
of the DNI, a retired Air Force senior officer and
an official from the Defense Intelligence Agency,
say it's difficult to know exactly what's going
on. But that, number one, the main points of
Putin is afraid of assassination attempts and
Putin did undergo treatment for cancer. Those two
points are being reported as being true, according
to this classified report. The three intelligence
officials also say that this makes the prospect of
nuclear war less likely, which has been a concern
for a while. They don't elaborate as to why, and
I'm not actually sure why they believe this report
about Putin's cancer treatment makes nuclear war
less likely. Maybe we'll get more information
about that. Also interesting, the Russian foreign
minister, Sergei Lavrov. Major propagandist.
He was asked about this notion of Putin being sick
in an interview last weekend on French television,
and he straight up denied it. He said, quote, I
don't think that a sane person can suspect any
signs of an illness or ailment in this man. And if
Sergei Lavrov is so vehemently denying something,
it genuinely might point to it being true
because the guy is just a constant and total
liar. So the bottom line here, according to the
Defense Intelligence Agency official, is Putin
is definitely sick. But whether he is close to
death is mere speculation. We just have no idea.
Natural question if someone has undergone
cancer treatment, well, what type of cancer?
Unclear. The speculation over the last two
months has been prostate cancer, thyroid cancer,
but it is merely speculation at this point. There
have also been speculations about a Parkinson's or
something, Parkinsonian. You could have cancer and
Parkinson's. There are now with the cancer piece,
more in focus. There's also speculation that the
Parkinsonian appearance may have been a result
of maybe medication or treatment. But again,
there are lots of speculative elements,
the one that seems to now be out of the realm
of speculation and into the line of fact
based on the classified report is, yes, cancer
of some kind and treatment in April. Will we ever
know the full truth? Maybe. I don't know. But
a very, very interesting report. And it seems
that what was believed early on indeed appears
to be, at least to some degree, now confirmed.